and
this energy's going down
with that energy
[Music]
because
so as she starts to lean
as she gets in this tilt
i'm hovering
at the edge of her energy to change her
shape
and then
hovering
right
here feel it come off
and keep that hovering going
do you see how loose this hand is
because it's in this hand
it's in this here
not this
watch it come off
see
it's in this
have to push
these two hands
the push
but the lead
is what creates the friction of the two
heads
what
you you're trying to dive under
with your weak center
so go back
she's just standing there do you see
she doesn't nothing happens to her body
that you turn your arm
nothing
go on
you don't you're you're using your left
hand
[Music]
and then
don't push them away
control it
right at the edge
right
then
it's in the two relationships so not
here
in the two
same feeling in the body
do you begin trying to dive under
thank you
so that little hopping that you're
feeling is you want to drop you want to
go here that's where you're comforted
but because it's
it's making you move
it's amazing
so
in the body
over here when you see me
go like
this
it's because you guys attack in stages
you're like this
if i punch you i don't go
i punch you right so when i come in
are you hungry
i'm gonna
[Music]
you see
really high you're attacking the arm
and see if you can sense this kind of
thing too pay attention
okay so you can see uh
uh
the force does not
have to be in straight lines
like you go oh it's it's locked into my
skeleton
you see so you know it's in it's in my
going up my arm into my shoulder
you can change the degrees of the force
you see
you can aim it anywhere okay so you
allow for that possibility
and uh what i'm going to do is set it
amy here
i'm going to aim here
okay
um
so not not there
i'll get the aim there
look what your look at your center
watch your center
okay
shoulder
and it's leaving you
but this didn't this not affected this
you see it tilted
and then that
i tilt
now if we watch
so i'm going
in
and you see how you change your pelvic
cycle it's fine don't worry i just want
you to notice something i'm not saying
that's right i just don't care
okay
um
now look how
you're turning your weight
you see so
tilt your pelvis angle that's an
absorption
easy
and then
it starts to turn and now your center is
not moving
just like
this one
okay so watch how it doesn't matter what
you do
yep there's that tilt again look how i
keep it moving
you see
so you see how you had to reach for the
ground i will keep one trajectory just
like you're keeping one right now into
the shoulder
not paying attention to what you
actually want to accomplish so you go
ahead and do your counters again you see
and then
i'm exactly where you are
you see so i have to do the feeling
yeah maybe put your hand down
and then i can come in and keep that
same feeling
on your body
so it goes
not up here
that's just a tilt
this relationship
oh
you want to go this way you see what i'm
not going to let you
see
you want to go down i can't feel it but
yeah i'm not going to let you it's in
your body
yeah that little inhalation like whoa
here's that same absorption
that i have to do
if she wants to go like this we're going
to go a little bit more like that you
see
in
you want to go here no
this relationship
all those little
you know
they're they're i call them cowards do
you see
um
they're good for me
because what she creates is
uh it's a counter because her body is
being
uh controlled
by the coq
vectors
do you see and
people in fights
will
disconnect
they'll they'll dismantle that so they
can get their counter do you see
so when my uke does that
i'm training
what looks like a kihon waza
but he's actually a guaza
because my
uke
keeps trying to pull their center out
of the koku
construct do you see
oh it's good for me
because i i'm basically doing gu
all the time
but
not good for use you can
because
of the process
by which you can do this skill that i'm
doing
okay
so uh imagine i disconnect you see
i'm going to do
i'll show you what you do she's going to
push into me
and you see how i did that
so
whom these are counters
so if i keep my
same construct
she'll she'll move me but it's a little
heavy for her because her her construct
is not that
organized doesn't have integrity
okay
so imagine
uh
when she pushes on me
i do those
dismantling you see and now i cannot i'm
never gonna control her center i'm gonna
have to do this externally
you see
so
what you're learning as uke
is
what it's like
to be in a you construct
so that you can go from i have no idea
what that why that's happening to me do
you get it
at first for example
uh
as you guys uh our testament to is it
looks very external
you see so you do your you do your
technique external everything's external
and then you start paying attention
she ends up turtling
you end up with this super tight grip
over here
or you have to really
pull them
do you see
or
uh you don't know how to do it so i have
to tell you how to do it you you go
flying around me
basically you you get them to do it
because it's all external okay
um
because i don't know what else to do
i can't
i've never felt it
but then after i feel it for the first
time
i can't understand it
do you see
so the traditional arts are like
understanding is never going to give it
to you
you trying to do it you trying to
understand it
is why you did the external stuff
so
the teacher is going to
uh
in a very
concentric way
repeat
the
what in essence is the possession
uh model okay
um or the communion model
with god so the energy
goes into your entire being you become a
vessel for it all okay in oh sensei's
tradition they didn't talk about it in
our
judeo-christian tradition of
oneness they actually talked about
possession
okay the kami came into you you see the
invisible came into you
so you had to act as a vessel
or right now you're like a vessel that
has no integrity or has lots of leaks
do you see and so the economy can't come
into you the energy cannot come into you
you keep dismantling it okay
so uh
what you're what the teacher is doing
is pouring in the energy so
she goes and you're like
well there it is you see that's the
energy but then in our fear or our pride
we go
you see how i did that
i pulled myself out of it
okay
but then the teacher
doesn't need you
doesn't need you to maintain shape do
you see the teacher's technique doesn't
need you to maintain shape okay so we
had
that little pelvis thing do you see that
she does to pull herself out of it that
she goes to pull herself doesn't matter
do you see
it's still in her you get so
i don't need her to do that it'll
improve my skill
but you are not getting the feeling of
it being
throughout your body
which is what i'm using
to do my skill
you see so for example
let's say uh
she does her little there you go and i
do my little thing and now we're back to
just external
stuff
do you get it in order for me
to
deal with her counter i have to keep my
same organization
in order to
adapt to her counter without going back
to external so your job as a
uke
is to let the teacher fill the vessel by
holding the shape the shape
okay
let me hear it's off
and she has to pull me
well i keep the shape
okay
right there it's off
you're not in her body anymore
nope
right there
you can see your the desperation in your
right hand you see
so you're confusing
this
you push
all right you didn't see that so you see
how you even here you want it to do that
even here in spooky you want it to
and i'm not going to do this
that's just knocking over just like this
so even as i grab from here
it will go into your center
you see
like that
[Music]
and all you have to do is
you have a job to do there it is
okay
so remember i already
uh stated that that you guys will
settle
and then you push you settle
and then you push because these are
bracing angles
okay
not
coq projection okay
so
you know
it's that's that same push do you see
okay it doesn't lie but i'm gonna go on
okay
all right so what i already said is
at contact
there it is
i
hang out on the edge of that control
do you see
so i don't want to push you
past it
i just
hang out on the edge of that
see so the way
you can tell is
uh push back
see she can't okay
it's not that she can't because i'm
trying to do that
it's just right at the edge
right at the edge
right here going there
is not
the same thing
it's going to go this way
do you see there's your balance you see
that watch go back
rewind your thumb
here you have balance
over here
you see
not here
over here
there it is right there there's no
desperation
okay go back stay there we're just
rewinding not here
it's
off boom
on
still long
totally
oh
so
again
it's not overpowering
[Music]
you have to watch
that
you feeling overpowered
does not
generate the will to power
and then you misunderstand this as
overpowering
okay
so
you have to go deeper
why do i feel
overpowered
maybe you'll raise that way
probably
right
we all are
and uh
you've been taught
watch out for this enemy
defeat them
overpower them
but
it's a life of fear
okay
so
um
you end up
just overpowering
other women
got it
okay so it's it's going off hey
and now it's starting to come back on
the feeling you up here
you're turning a little shy it's a
little shy on the turn
keep going
and now you don't have that feeling
anymore
find the center finder center again
and now you have it again right there
but that's a lot of not have it okay
okay so earlier
i discussed how
uh it does not have to travel in
straight line you remember that and
energy is not
energy does not have to travel in a
straight line your your uh your material
your secular material mind
only sees straight lines okay
um
but
you want to let go of those things so
energy does not have to travel in a
straight line
and also energy does not require certain
shape
okay
so what you're doing
is you're con you you're thinking even
though i told you you're not
you're thinking uh
this pushing thing you see
um
but
the example i gave where you're just
touching
this is a horizontal touch if you pay
attention
but on the
horizontal touch you see
you get it and uh also the fact that it
would mechanically you would go that
would be slippery do you see
um
but it doesn't require the
the grip you just you you you match her
energy
okay i'm gonna match her energy and then
you will stick to it because energy
doesn't realize it's from two different
sources it's just one energy and you
generate friction okay
um a ikea adhesion got it so it doesn't
require a certain shape
wherever you're touching
you can do call q or aiki okay
so
let us get to
uh
let's just correct one thing you start
to go shy here you see that okay so i
just want you to feel it it there's that
this would be the other mistakes
you see
but
i and keep you right at that edge
right at that edge do you see that okay
all right so now let's look at i'm over
here
do you see
this is a shape different from the other
shape
but you only recognize straight lines
so here i am
and i'm not doing a wrist lock
just wherever i'm touching
i'm keeping that same thing can you see
so
a q
would be
when i go here
you stopped
until
i get your center again okay
so
uh
boom
wherever i'm touching
so it's not this
wherever i'm touching you you can see
it's the two it's the two you feel the
the great friction there okay
so it's not
doing nothing or
back to this
the two
oh
so if you want you can't do it with this
hand you can't do it with this hand do
you see still in your body for example
push back you see can't push
same thing
so what i'm trying to say
is
keep this feeling
as you go to transition
keep the same feeling hey
don't go oh i feel her center
then let me wait
and then i'll get back into it
okay
there's the same feeling
same feeling the two hands feel
so in them
[Music]
now i'm exaggerating
the bringing around so you can feel that
you're coming around because i have your
centered you see martially you want to
put the
the inside shoulder down
[Music]
but
marshally
you cannot do it
where some of you are wanting to do it
so we'll just get here and you go like
this
do you see
uh
because i have to be stronger than
if i'm not stronger than her i'm
okay most times you get laid down for
you and kicks their turtle out
that's not marshall
usually what someone does
when you have the arm bar
is
they'll keep resisting
with the outer post
very decent
and so
trying to get this under you use your
outer post
so i use the outer post as my next
projection in other words the energy she
sends into me i call cue it down
post
when you see it it's what makes her fall
so
even as
marshall as getting that shoulder down
as
quickly as possible
um you can't put it directly under you
because you lose the center
and when they post
you're not getting that down unless
you're way stronger than them
okay
so
even though for training purposes i'm
moving your center quite a bit to extend
the feeling
you see to to give you a chance to
become a vessel for the energy
um
it's still more related to a martial
application than the other one where
they're standing still and then you just
force them down
where luka just lays down before okay
it's a little in front of her you see
right here you're just pushing through
her center's staying still
now you got to move it all the way
around because you all at once you got
to bring it all the way around as
opposed to incrementally bringing it
just stand stand still stand still
and now you find your inside elbow hand
but that's
external in front of her center
keep going
and look how in order to get your right
hand in place
look how dominant your left hand has to
be on the grip you see okay
okay
okay so right here
you leave it all there
and then this hand is now on the outside
of you
now you don't you know not to push here
because it's your inner deltoid so you
death grip this hand
to bring it back underneath your
centerpiece
off as it goes off
pull it
and then you get then you can put it
down here but here's the thing
uh
grip really hard okay
so i can barely get
it off
and it took a while in that time you're
not
see
so
while you're not necessarily
overpowering the elbow because you're
using sound body mechanics
you did have to overpower the grip okay
so
we'll get to that part
but what i'm saying is this keeps moving
you see that
so
right where i touch you i keep that same
feeling
it's not that
i'm going here
and then i'm making
the same feeling
so we'll slow it down
we'll get to where we need to be here we
are right here
this here right here these two hands
keep you moving
and then i enter not on a straight line
but on a curve
look how my waist is turning
and look how far into
and then a
turn so you can see the uk stays still
that's different the udemy angle is
straight
uh
and then there's a delay
for
when i bring the elbow hand back into
play and then a stress
on the
grip at the wrist
you see so when you lose the internal
skills all these external problems come
up okay so
what we want to do
again
is
here
with this touch this this touch you see
everything keeps moving
everything keeps moving you see
then you just enter in when the yin
space creates when the in space
moves amazing
so
rather than your solution
this
keep them moving and feeling okay and
then it'll open itself up you will find
the elbow okay